there's a lot of talk in the Creator
Community now about burnout you know
people one year in on their career and
they're burning out it's like well I've
been doing this for 14 years and haven't
burnt out yet I still love the process
of doing the thing so what is work is
this work like it's not for me when it's
in my calendar it's like oh cool I get
to talk to Sean today this would be a
fun conversation the second it becomes
like oh man I don't want to go on this
podcast then what am I doing I should
stop and move on to something else and
same thing with making videos making
videos I like the process of doing it
the the profiles that we do I need for
me I listen to every morning I I need
them in my life and so even if nobody
liked them I would still have a skeleton
team doing it for me just so that I had
something every morning to watch and I
think what ends up happening is a lot of
entrepreneurs they get caught up on
running their business and just trying
to play to the algorithm they end up
falling out of love with the thing that
they're doing in the first place which
then leads to burnout which then leads
to unhappiness I like waking up every
day and doing what I'm doing need
motivation watch your top 10 with hash
believe Nation hey it's EV car Michael
and I make these videos because I need
them because being around successful
entrepreneurs who are pushing who are
driving who are doing amazing things
gives me that extra little motivational
inspirational boost in the morning every
day to help me go off and accomplish
great things too and I hope that this
video gives you that inspiration as well
so today let's learn from one of the
best my husband Evan carmichel in our
take on his top 10 rules for Success
enjoy
the biggest thing that I struggled with
at the beginning was
belief and and still now but I'm I'm a
lot more confident have more self-belief
now than I did 5 years ago or 10 years
ago or whatever um when I started my
channel there was a YouTuber with a
million subscribers like it wasn't even
a thing I was just making videos just
because I wanted to serve like if 50
people saw the video like wow 50 people
saw this great let's go right but it's
still the thing that I need most for for
the next level and I find that that's
that's C right like if your main thing
is
pivoting your biggest strength is that
you pivoted your biggest check is that
you helped other people pivot and the
biggest thing holding you back is like
the next
pivot what's the next pivot when people
ask like what's the what's the secret to
uh health and I think a lot lot of
people default to diet and sleep and you
know a lot of the typical things but for
at least for me my answer the secret to
health is actually loving the work that
you're doing I think if you woke up
every day and felt like I love what I'm
about to do today I'm gonna go serve
somebody and it's not that sleep's not
important because it is and diet it's
not important what it is but I think
there's a lot of people who are in great
physical shape or who have the perfect
you know sleep routine or the perfect
diet who who hate their lives yeah where
I think if you just if you really love
the work that you're doing I think
that's a secret to a long healthy happy
life and everything flows from there and
so connecting to your purpose
understanding how you can serve that
your purpose comes from your pain you
know you mentioned it that you want to
help other people who basically are
struggling with the same thing that you
struggled with and that's the best like
when you find somebody who's basically
the same as you but you're just a little
bit further along on the journey and you
struggled and you suffered and you you
know almost exhausted all the options
and you finally found the path and you
can shortcut that path for somebody else
it's the best feeling ever how do you
push through any of the parts of the job
that are like yeah but it this just has
to get done whether it's accounting or
any any elements that just are not your
jam yeah so you know a couple rules I
guess that have served me the first is
if it has to get done once uh and I need
to do it I'll do it as soon as it
becomes an ongoing thing it's it's a
it's eliminate automate delegate in that
order like does it have to get done if
yes can I automate it if if no can I uh
delegate it to somebody else so you
mention accounting that is probably the
thing entrepreneurs like the least you
know shout out to all the great
accountants out there uh shout out to
the lawyers who review our contracts and
that's a disaster um but yeah I mean I
gave that up that was one of the first
things I gave up uh inside of my video
business editing I didn't want to do was
I hated editing and shout out to all the
great editors who love doing that we've
got four or five editors on our team um
and they do great work and they don't
want to be in front of the camera they
want to edit so cool uh and so if it's
an ongoing thing I try to get it off my
plate as quickly as possible and the
path especially at the beginning is
trying to figure out inside my mission
how can I make enough money to be able
to hire team to take away the things
that I don't want to do where a lot of
times entrepreneurs are thinking just
big big mission out of the gate which is
awesome and inside that instead of
worrying about how to build a giant
brand out of the gate focus on how do I
make my first 100,000 how do I make my
first half million that then that gets
me money to be able to quit my job do
this full-time give myself some
Financial stability but then also hire
team to take care of the things that I
don't want to do also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned learned in this
video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there was there a moment that you recall
where this where this Mission became
very clear to you yeah I talk about it a
lot in in my book your one word yeah
and I had my website and my web before I
had my YouTube channel I had my website
we had 100,000 B of content and all
these big name people W for the website
and I was trying to figure what my tag
line was what's the slow bit with my
website and I I didn't settle anything
that I liked I had you know over 100
million entrepreneurs helped the champ
and like all these things and nothing
really Li it and I went to go uh Watch
The Steve Jobs movie uh and out of that
I I the word believe came
up and like I really like Bel this
is but then I I can't like that's too
broad leap us too it's like it's it's
ourselves we talk ourselves out from the
Big Ideas it's not even our friends and
family like you you have a bold idea and
then right away your head tells you why
you can't do it why you're not good
enough so so I then went like can't just
be believed but it's got be believe in
self believe in entrepreneurs believe it
and I came up with all the variations
and I slept on it the next day it came
back just like
believe so I I don't know let me let me
test it and so I sent the newsletter out
to my email list is talking about
believe and ended up being the best
newsletter ter of engage when clicks and
my sister said that she saw it and she
had she'd like the newsletter which is
like a compliment in the backand you
know theistic m I made a video about
believe and my best video on my YouTube
channel had 100,000 views at the time
took a year to get there and I was so
proud of it 100,000 views is great the
video believe hit 100,000 in a month and
now was in a millions of of views for
that video and so thought that believe
is the magical thing it's a magical
thing for me and so I I tiptoed into it
then eventually went all in on just okay
I'm going to be the Bel gu I still need
it for myself and I still need it like
every time I learn it I want to go teach
other people as well so my biggest
strength is belief and my biggest
weakness is belief to do the next thing
the brand is usually the biggest way to
long-term have success with your company
but it takes a while to build a brand I
mean you've been you've been at it you
know lots of people been at it like it
takes a while to build a brand and a lot
of people fizzle out along the way and
they don't know how to generate
immediate Revenue which is where the
other two shows come in uh so if you
need to make money this year or right
away like in the next 3 weeks you can do
it through YouTube just not through
thought leadership content if you're
doing influencer marketing or you're
going to run pre-roll YouTube
commercials cool that's just direct
marketing and so you can do that you
just track those it lead to conversions
for you and that's definitely play
that's not where I would be an expert at
uh throwing somebody on your team who's
just at a university or whatever that is
usually an attempt to build brand right
we're trying to create our own content
somehow to build brand uh it's usually
not a super effective way to do it um
but the direct marketing side is very uh
tangible is huge a lot of people are
doing it a lot of big money is coming
into YouTube because the ad policies are
far stric is but but less strict than
Facebook and Instagram so people are
getting the higher Roi off of YouTube
ads than they are on Facebook and
Instagram what's the point of a morning
routine at least for me it's to get a
feeling so yeah a lot of times people
will just check the box like I did this
I did this I did this I did this okay
cool but do you feel ready to take on
the day because if not then there's
either something wrong in your routine
or you did it uh half-heartedly and you
got to do it with more intention um I
remember I was doing an event in New
Mexico and uh a woman was in the front
row of my event and I asked her what's
the most important part of your morning
routine and she said I do the rosary so
she takes out her her you know prayer uh
the rosary and starts doing her prayers
I say well okay so what's the what's the
point of doing the rosies like well by
the end of it I feel
connected to what I'm doing and ready to
go and start my day awesome how many
times you actually feel connected like
by the end you do in the rosary how much
time how many times what percentage of
the days do you actually feel connected
and ready to go and start the day and
she said like
40% so the other 60% she's she's doing
the words she's doing the action she's
saying it but she doesn't feel connected
because she's also stressed out about
something else because she's also making
breakfast because she's also watching
some video because she's she's doing
something else like well there's nothing
wrong with what you're doing you're just
not doing it with the intention that is
required great keep doing the rosary but
now focus in on doing it with the right
intention because the whole point of the
morning routine is to get the feeling so
I think a lot of a lot of people a lot
of u a lot of entrepreneurs a lot of
people who are go-getters and action
takers we love the feeling of just like
check check check we check the box they
did it but if you don't have the feeling
of ready to take on the day with B B
nness with courage with service with
belief then either go back and do it
again or add something to your morning
routine or or tweak it up a bit because
for me at least the point of the morning
routine is to get the feeling so you're
ready to take on the day do you ever
have moments where you get out of
alignment with your
mission uh yeah not in a big way a lot
of micro like what um saying yes to the
it's usually it usually would involve
saying yes to something that I don't
want to disappoint somebody on but I
shouldn't have said yes I think we get a
feeling of whether something is good for
you or not right even coming here and
saying yes why this like my team is
pissed that I'm here because I'm behind
I just came from Arizona I'm going to
Orlando next I'm going back to Arizona
and they like we have this thing in the
middle and like I me we need you on all
these Saints right and they're not p p
but like I'm now not doing stuff for my
team because this right uh but fine it
felt right talk to you it was great okay
we're going to spend extra time awesome
let's do it right even even our crew
here was helping helping set this up
right I was supposed to do a a a show
with Ramy
and and they said well why don't we come
here I no I didn't know him and I didn't
really know you so like okay well but it
felt right what is your number one tip
or strategy to help us sell more
understand your most important goal and
then create the show that helps you
accomplish that goal like YouTube can
serve in a lot of different ways most
people think of it just as a place to be
an influencer and build a brand and and
it is if you want long-term success
building a brand and having people beat
a path to your door is huge but that
doesn't happen in you know 30 days uh so
if your number one goal is I need to
make sales in 30 days cool start a
YouTube show around Business Development
let's go close my biggest challenge on a
day-to-day I'd say now is not accounting
or doing um you know grunt work or
things I don't want to do it's more
pushing harder you know I think good is
the enemy of great and so things are
really good and and it's honestly great
I mean if you look at a a Global
Perspective everybody listening to this
show is in a great like you have
internet you know globally you're you're
way ahead of a lot of people um you have
food you have a bed so you're you're way
ahead already of a lot of the world but
but you could do more and that's the
biggest push that's why I need Jay-Z in
my ear and Oprah Winfrey in my ear and
and Steve Jobs in my ear and these
people that's why I make the videos I do
because it's easy to wake up and just
keep doing the same it's hard to wake up
and push yourself to do something that
you haven't done before to to believe in
the next version of what you could
become and that's um that's an ongoing
struggle the only thing you're missing
is momentum you you've got all the tools
available to you it has never been
easier to build your dreams to reach an
audience to create the company you want
never easier all you're missing is
momentum sustained daily everpresent
momentum and today I'm going to show you
how to get it one of the only reasons
why I've had success on YouTube is I
just kept going when I first started on
the platform 11 years ago it's crazy
that it's been that long you can kind of
see some of the awards behind me here
behind the the books by build to serve
it's an amazing book 11 years ago when I
first started my first video was on Walt
Disney I had my friend Mark Dreer huge
friend of the channel come in and help
film it for me and and help edit for me
and in the first year of that video
being up there were only three comments
on it one was my mom one was my older
sister and one was some other random guy
who commented on my video right in a
year of my first video going up only one
person that I didn't know commented on
the
video YouTube at the time was not a long
form platform YouTube 11 years ago was
something that people were posting
really silly meme videos and just jokes
and pranks but really short form videos
nobody was making long videos 10 minute
videos 12 minute video it didn't exist
and it took me 5 years to get to 7,000
subscribers I knew because that's when I
passed 1 million views after 5 years I
crossed a million views and I got 7,000
subscribers and then in the past 6 years
it's gone from 7,000 subscribers to 2.
whatever million and a million views to
300 whatever million views I just kept
at it now my journey doesn't have to be
your journey it doesn't have to take you
that long if you're trying to build up a
YouTube channel it may but it doesn't
have to one I'm super introverted and
and nervous and and filming and even now
stuff makes me nervous get in front of
the camera because I want every video to
be the best that I've ever done YouTube
at the time was not an educational
platform and has changed so there's lots
that was against me but the only reason
why I've passed so many other creators
is just because I kept going because I
had the thing that most people Miss
which is momentum the only thing you're
you're missing is momentum it was
actually sad for me for when I passed
some of the speakers that I looked up to
and I aspired to be like from a speaker
point of view because I figured these
guys are so much more talented than me
these guys have so many more abilities
than me they're they're more naturally
gifted and they put in so much work to
be great speakers and it made me sad
when I passed them on YouTube because I
felt man these guys they should be out
there more I I feel like their message
needs to be heard the only difference
was I was just putting in more work on
YouTube they're off doing their other
things as well but from a YouTube
perspective I was just building more
momentum I just had more sustained
energy to it and you see this so often
with entrepreneurs not just YouTube
entrepreneurs so often you got a great
idea and you start and there's so much
energy and momentum and then and then
you don't get immediate results and so
you stop and then you get motivated
again and you keep going and then and
then you quit again and you and you give
up it's that sustained Evergreen ongoing
daily momentum that's you're missing
even if it's just an hour a day maybe
you have a job you need to survive
awesome I understand yes pay the bill
bills you don't have to burn all the
boats and burn all the bridges as the
only way that this business is going to
take off sustain momentum every single
day has to be part of what you're doing
and so I've had success on YouTube
because I've made 6,000 videos again I'm
not super talented uh took me a long
time to get here I'm I'm a result of
just every day getting up and doing the
work and chances are whoever your heroes
are whether it's Tony Robbins or Steve
Jobs or Oprah winf whoever it is look at
their story it was every day getting up
doing the work even if they weren't
getting results knowing that the only
thing missing the only thing you are
missing is that sustained momentum
because you're a genius you have a great
idea that idea needs to be birthed into
the world you're just not doing enough
daily action to make it actually happen
as a Creator we often tend to kind of
compare ourselves to other others and
and lose the focus of the people who are
already here who are already following
us and and enjoying the stuff we have
showing love and we try to kind of focus
on the stuff we don't have so so that
one really resonated this is one of the
things that helped me back the most
because my biggest fear is disappointing
people my biggest fear is that I'm going
to I'm going to get on stage or I'm
going to come to an interview and I'm
going to let you down and I'm not going
to have an answer and I'm not going to
know what to say and I don't want to
waste your time I don't want to waste
the audience's time and that used to
hold me back a lot from keeping the
momentum going might start one thing and
then like there's an opportunity and and
then say no or cancel or or back out or
like hope they would cancel on me
because my I would be afraid that I
would disappoint people so the thing
that always saved me that I still use
today is focus on who you are serving
you know like focus on who you are
serving instead of who you aren't we in
in the comparison game of starting a
YouTube channel or starting an Instagram
account or getting on Tik Tok it's
always easy to look at well but look at
look at whoever you know look at the
number one look at what Joe Rogan's
doing or look at what Evan carmichel is
doing or look at what whoever else is
doing and the game of who you're not
never ends there's always somebody who's
better than you at something right like
the only thing that you're best in the
world that is being Teemo right the only
thing I'm best in the world is being EV
kak there's always people who are better
than me at all these other skill sets
that I want to learn and get better at
and that's great because we never want
to stop learning you never want to have
it all figured out we want to be able to
climb forever but if you're only living
in the world of I'm not enough and like
who you're comparing yourself to I think
people that's what will often lead to
burnout that's what lead to people
quitting that's what lead to people
killing their momentum as opposed to
saying I am helping people right like
focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not so in my first videos my
first video on
YouTube had three comments on it in a
year
and one was my mom and one was my sister
and then one was some random guy you
know I was like so in a year of my first
video going up where people are like I
didn't get any comment man my first
video for a year only had one comment by
some random guy who I didn't know and I
saw that and like hey somebody commented
on my video this is
great and so if you can focus on people
you know that they post something
Instagram and they have 40 views on a
video and he say I'm such a failure only
40 people saw this video well imagine if
if you were going to go speak at a
library or or a school event or
something like 40 people showed up
wouldn't you be excited wouldn't you be
nervous wouldn't you be like oh my God
there's 40 people here coming to see me
but because it's it's online we feel
like we're just a failure cuz somebody
else posted one and they got 40,000 and
you're sitting here with 40 and so I
always just focused on who I was serving
those 40 people like 40 people watch
this video and for maybe for one of
those people that this was a
life-changing video that for one person
the thing that I said was the piece of
advice that they needed to move the
needle forward in their life and that
always gave me
more fulfillment more happiness more
positivity knowing that I am helping
some people and that I can continue to
help more and when you start doing the
work to help and focus on those 40 they
take you to the 40,000 like if you do a
great job nurturing your community then
they take you to their friends and their
friends and their friends and that's how
you build up and grow so yeah I think um
the comparison game can often uh hold us
back there's some Advanced strategies
around that that can work but when you
focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not I think it leads to a lot
more happiness which leads to a lot more
momentum as well if you look at my
YouTube career I wasn't super talented
there's not a lot of entertainment on
the videos um they're not coming for my
dashing good looks the only thing I did
was I just kept going most people quit I
just kept going but most people don't
have that stubbornness consistency for
anything like you are what you
consistently do if you eat one chocolate
bar you're fine if you a chocolate bar
every meal you're going to be kind of
screwed over tie yourself Worth to the
effort you're putting in on releasing
whatever the thing is like if you're you
want to be great at podcasting if you
did a podcast a month how many years
does it take to catch up to 365 it's
like it's never going to happen whatever
goals you have when you take consistent
action you're going to win on your
mission that you're on what challenges
with that format that you've built uh
have you faced for what's next and
what's been the advantage of that format
for what you've been able to build and
the impact that you're making in the
world my biggest limitation is still
lack of
belief
so people say but you're the belief guy
it's like yeah but I believe in myself
to do the things that I've done now but
to do the next the next big thing I
don't believe in myself to do the next
big so I still need the channel for
myself because I want to wake up and
have Oprah Winfrey or Steve Jobs or Elon
musk or whoever it is Whispering
messages in my ear to get me going to do
the next thing um one of my my uh talk
about the format of of giving tribute to
other people uh at the beginning it was
just hey I've learned this from these
people and I think you might be able to
learn too I was just hoping to shortcut
the path CU my my worst day in my first
business was when I said I quit on my
business partner and I woke up the next
day and said I can't quit yet cuz I'm
going to regret this if I don't figure
this out at least at least if it doesn't
work out fine but at least know that I
gave it everything because I don't want
to look back and say ah I wish I just
tried a little bit harder but I couldn't
keep going the way that I was going so I
had to find another path and the thing
that came to me was I can't be the first
person to try to solve this problem like
somebody's figured this out why don't I
just model success like that wasn't
model success wasn't words that I would
use you know it's probably a lot more
clumsy but I can't be the first person
to figure F this out somebody's done it
and that's where I studied Bill Gates
like Bill Gates had a like who's got a
software company I had a software
company who's got a successful software
company Bill Gates came to mind like I
this was not very Advanced planning it's
just top of Dome uh so okay how did
Microsoft get started and how did he
build like not so much how did how does
Bill Gates make an extra million dollars
now who cares but like 0 to one how did
you do that and it was through
Partnerships and and learning how he
applied at Microsoft I brought that to
my business and quickly after had my
first check for
$135,000 and that may not seem like a
lot but when you're making 300 bucks a
month like 13 and a5k it's like holy cow
this is a grand slim here and more
importantly I could do that again that
was just one deal I could close more
deals so the idea the strategy there was
model success find people who have done
this and put that to use in your
business or your life and so I I then
went on this mission to continue learn
learning how I can model other people's
success and then I that eventually
became a YouTube channel where I shared
a lot of messages um a surprising
benefit of that has been I've gotten to
meet some of these people you know like
I was just profiling some of them and
then now I get to do interviews with
them or go hang out with them or go to
their houses and some of them become
friends which was never part of the idea
of what I could do was just hey I love
your
message I'm trying to get it out to the
world cuz if I learn from it maybe other
people like me can learn from it and
it's been amazing to be able to Foster
lot of those connections too we give up
too easily on our goals because we
proven to ourselves that we can't follow
through in our goals every time you set
a goal and you don't follow through
you're creating the pattern in your head
the mindset the identity that I'm the
kind of person who doesn't follow
through so what happens the next time
you set a goal well your your brain will
kick in to say you're not going to do
that how many times have you set a goal
for yourself it might be some big giant
goal right like I'm going to crush this
year and I'm going to be here by the end
of the year awesome might be some big
goal but chances are even the little
ones even the little goals like I'm
going to work out today or I'm going to
eat well today or I'm going to make that
call today how many times have you set
even a little goal for yourself and then
not follow through you didn't do it
you're not allowed to do that anymore
you have to be very intentional about
the goals you set for yourself and then
once you set them you have to follow
through because what's happening is you
don't believe you
anymore the next time you come up with
another goal you say I'm going to create
this thing I'm going to get this thing
done you might believe it in the half
second that you decided you're going to
do
it and then what happens your brain's
going to take over and say you're not
going to do that thing are you
crazy what makes you think you're going
to do that you didn't do these other
hundred things you said you were going
to do
either your goals don't count till
they're
hard and they it starts with as soon as
you set a goal you follow through and
expect it to be difficult if it's easy
it's a gift expect it to be difficult
and show yourself that you do difficult
things what advice would you give to
this person to kind of I don't know if
it's like to shake things up in their
world or just to give them momentum wow
so there's a lot there uh I would want
to know more about the individual but
some generic advice one I would expect
to suck at the start I would expect a
struggle at the start I think people
expect to be amazing at the start and
then they're shocked by how hard it is
when they actually get out and go uh
certainly my case I expected to be doing
way better than I I was at the beginning
and I was actually too embarrassed to
tell my friends and to a shame that like
I was making no money and I couldn't
come out to dinner or birthday parties
not because I was too busy but because
that 20 bucks was too much for me to go
out for a night so expect to suck at the
start um I think remembering your why
remembering what you're doing remember
the big ambition that you have I think
if you started a business just to try to
make money you will fail because it's
going to get hard and it's a deep
passion for what you do that helps you
through those tough times that you would
keep doing it even if you weren't making
any money because you just love it some
it's it's a part of you what what this
is is a part of you you have to keep
doing it if you stop it a piece of you
dies like that's what you need to find
and so Mak money is important too but
it's never number one there's got to be
something more important if you only did
it to make money you're going to fail
how you started to create your YouTube
channel because me myself along with
many other YouTubers out there are
people who want to build their YouTube
following H how what do we do how do how
do we start to build and grow our
YouTube channel one is you just start I
think people are in their head too much
I think
people they're trying to be perfect
you're you're some big B impossible plan
up in your head and then as a result you
don't do anything so you need to start
you need phone film your phone up turn
it sideways and start to film and post
your first video right what Marlo suck
first video is going to be terrible like
ever in your life like you got up on a
bicycle and you fell off you know you
didn't just get up and ride so don't
expect to get on YouTube and be great on
camera you know you you have great like
even you you've got great speaking
skills and you're great with people and
you love interviewing you love talking
it's still a learning process to get
great in front of the camera some people
can short shortcut that path but it's
still a path and so just start get out
of your way stop being perfect expect it
to suck and just start two I would say
you need to be consistent so it doesn't
matter where you start where you start
is not going to be where you finish but
you have to move and you got to move
consistently and so there's a great
quote I think it was Will Smith but was
talking about how I'm not responsible
for where I started you know I was born
where I was born I can't change that but
I'm responsible for where I finish I get
to control where I go in life no matter
where I started and so people blame
their start and then they don't move but
it's like it's on you doesn't matter
where you came from you you can go
anywhere uh and so consistency you got
to practice you got to get better you
got to make daily content if you want to
get good at something if you want to if
you want to be Oprah Winfree level
Talent at something you have to do it
daily you know if you if you were making
a video a week you're just never going
to get world class at that thing just
like anything else if you if you did
anything else once a week you would
never become world class at that thing
might get decently good if you want to
be a chef and you're only practicing
cooking once a week you're never going
to be the oer Winfree of cook of of that
right you're never going to do it so you
need to practice more so one just start
start with what you have start
immediately today like happy New Year
let's start right now today we're going
we're not waiting and then every day you
need to practice you need to practice
practice and you will slowly get better
people don't lean into their dreams
because they're afraid you're afraid of
it not working you're afraid of people
judging you you're afraid of you being a
failure but if you never lean into your
dream you'll always know that you are
capable of more and regret the fact that
you never had the courage to really take
your shot so I think we constantly go
through this I I recently went through
this late last year where I got invited
to speak at Brendan Bard's event and
couple thousand people in the room and
up until that point I hadn't done a big
speaking event for a while i' done a lot
of small events small small meetups uh
even small speaking engagements but a
couple thousand people I hadn't done in
a while and in my head I was telling
myself I just want to do a Q&A Q&A is
the easiest for me it's the most fun for
me it's the easiest for me all I have to
do is show up and so I I told them hey
what if we just did a Q&A and one of the
hosts either Brandon or Ethan or or Dean
or one of the people there at the at the
event can interview me we'll do Q&A and
then we'll open up to the audience
because that's the most fun knowing that
it's helping somebody else in the
audience and they said we don't really
want to do that
format I like okay no problem no problem
I'm in I'll speak and at the two events
prior I did Q&A I I I brought it up to
the organizer they like the idea and
then we went to Q&A and I shine in Q&A
and again I love it I'm great at it but
it also is a easy crutch for me because
I don't need to prepare for anything I
don't need to have uh uh you know
PowerPoint I don't need to have a deck
uh I don't even really need to think
that much about what I'm going to say
because it's always bouncing off
whatever the other person wants to talk
about if I didn't show up though if I
didn't go if I didn't say yes if I
sabotaged it I would have missed out on
such an amazing opportunity right from
that one event where I spoke on
Brendan's stage couple thousand people
he then invited me back to come and
speak again in Puerto Rico to his big
Mastermind group not big people more big
people pay through to 50K to be there
and then he invited me to Mastermind
with him and Dean and his his homies to
help him in his business and me and mine
as well if I sabotaged myself and said
no I only want to do
Q&A I wouldn't have gotten that
opportunity and so even though I was
super afraid I said yes even though I
tried to push you towards something else
that was more comfortable for me I said
yes and so it's leaning into the dream
the reality for me was I was just afraid
we all want to wake up and feel like
what we do matters if you woke up and
you felt every day that you don't matter
to somebody else that the work you do is
meaningless it doesn't matter that's the
path down to anxiety stress depression
suicides where a lot of people a lot of
people wake up and feel like just
today's doesn't matter nobody cares if I
show up or not but on the other hand if
you felt like today's going to matter
today it it'll mean something I'm going
to make something I'm going to show up
for somebody it's going to touch maybe
not a million lives but like one
person's life if you're going to show up
and you're going to take your mom to
brunch and it's going to touch her life
and so we all want to feel like the work
that we do matters people will love
helping the most are the people who
currently are who we used to be so when
I said your purpose comes from your pain
whatever you struggled through that made
you feel like The Biggest Loser of all
time is now what you want to help other
people through cuz there's lots of
people right now who feel like that
loser and they learn from you in a way
that they won't learn from me or Eddie
or Oprah or somebody else cuz you have a
different story helping and serving is
hardwired into our brains you know it's
the same they did functional MRIs on
people's brains and found the same part
of the brain lights up when you're
serving or helping as when you're having
food and having sex so it's like it we
We crave the desire to want to help
people but there's a difference between
just helping somebody cross the street
or holding the door for somebody or
buying the coffee like these little acts
of kindness
versus when you see somebody who's like
you and you help them overcome something
that then years later like when Eddie
says five years ago I don't know when I
talked to you hav picked up the phone
and called me and how much of a
difference it made right that's that's
the stuff that makes me feel I don't
even remember I don't remember talking
to
any show you the email you'll get a kick
out of it you I mean I remember you
outside the bathroom
so but like that those are the kind of
things that feel really good it makes me
want to keep doing it right that Eddie
said hey you took a chance on me and
gave me half an hour of your time or
however long we talked when I was just
getting started I mean I do that for a
ton of people who also don't go anywhere
right is it so it's not like it's great
to have success Tory but not everybody
turns out to be an Eddie as well uh but
that becomes proof that I should keep
doing it makes me feel good right you
stopping me outside the bathroom leading
to this you know we have a good
conversation it makes me want to say yes
to the next guy if it's a total you know
like a disaster and we the building's
locked and his microphone's not set up
and it's like oh my maybe I don't say
yes to the next guy I don't know
right so but we all want to feel like
the work we do matters isn't important
to people and every time we feel that it
does so much more for our soul than just
holding the door for somebody or doing a
random act of kindness in what way did
you get better and what did you invest
in so it was it was mindset and skill
set so the mindset I I'm introverted I'm
shy that doesn't come across on like
interviews like this but um I don't like
the spotlight I don't like being I don't
like being on stage um it makes me
nervous I it's not it's not enjoyable
just came back from a 3day event in
Vegas where I was speaking with with
Gary ve and um Patrick mavid and other
great speakers on stage and I don't like
being on stage I like the effect it
creates on the hallway afterwards to go
help people so I'll
I'm the only speaker who sticks around
and then I stay for hours in the hallway
talking to people um because they'll
come up to me and ask me questions based
off of my talk where normally I would I
wouldn't go up to anybody and talk to
them not because I'm I'm too good for
them but because I'm afraid you know I'm
introverted and shy um but we still want
to serve and so that was that was a huge
breakthrough for me when I realized even
though I'm introverted and shy I still
want to serve I still want to help and
all my models at the time if you look at
who's on TV you just see the people who
are big mouth and extroverted in the
life of the party and like that wasn't
me so I thought oh like to do that you
know I'm at the same agency as Mal
Robbins and Grant Cardone and both of
them are very out outwards focused and
like the life of the party and extrovert
and love talking to people um and just
that wasn't me so I I it took a while
for me once I tied it to service then it
was an unlock it's like this not about
me it's about the people you can help
and then that became like oh okay but
how does an introvert make a lot of
YouTube videos and win I don't know but
we'll just figure it out you know like
let's try let's see what happens um and
then the second part of that was was
getting help and communication and
getting once I decided to take it more
seriously that I realized oh I should be
doing more then then um yeah just
getting coaching and getting help and
watch my videos back and becoming a
better speaker um so people can get
there a lot faster it's not like oh once
you have a th000 subscribers or 100,000
subscribers or a million subscribers or
whatever it is then instantly everything
gets better it's much more about are you
are you good enough are you have the
skill set and the talent and the mindset
to actually make great content and
obviously the more repetition you put in
the better but but getting coaching and
getting help and getting people to give
you guidance um really helped me too the
number one rule if you want to make more
money is you have to bring more value
want to make money quickly provide value
quickly want to make tons of money
provide tons of value if you are not
making money yet it's because people
don't see the value that you bring and
we're going to change that in this video
so one of the first people that I had
any kind of arrangement with on the top
10 series that I had on my channel was
Tony Robbins I made a video on Tony
Robbins I don't know how many years ago
now the the first top 10 that I did on
him and his team put it on his YouTube
channel so it may still be there if you
go to his YouTube channel and then look
at the playlist you'll see that one of
those videos is the video that I made on
him so many years back and I started
trying to bring as much value to his
team as possible now Ton's a really busy
guy uh I'd loved him from all the books
that he's written and and the CD
programs that I listen to I hadn't been
to an event yet at that point and I was
just trying to bring value to Tony's
team I didn't know him personally yet
and it frustrated me that he wasn't more
on YouTube and I thought hey this guy
needs to be on more on YouTube I want
more content for my channel and I just
think I think the world needs more
amazing speakers and thought leaders out
there creating content on YouTube so
people can learn and so I kept in touch
with this team and I said hey I'd love
to help promote Tony I'd love to help
you with your YouTube channel I'd love
to have Tony on my channel and and I
just kept trying to find ways to bring
value to his team consistently and
following up and finally here's what
happened finally they agreed hey yeah
let's have Tony come and do an interview
on your team and finally they said hey
on your channel and I was so excited I
was super nervous I have Tony Robbins on
my channel it's going to be a big deal
and then like the day of or the day
before he had to cancel for for
something happened something came up on
his schedule no problem he had to cancel
and all of the nerves and energy is like
oh no now now led to disappointment that
is finally going to happen and then it's
not going to happen and he said we'll
try to we'll try to book it in as soon
as possible to get to get it happening
cuz Tony wants to be on your channel
great it took 2 years before we actually
got Tony on the channel afterwards two
years and and that's not that's not the
throw shade of Tony I love him he he's
busy he's doing his own thing I wasn't
bringing enough value to to make it
sooner uh but what I did was I kept in
touch I I kept following up not just
saying hey is Tony ready yet hey is Tony
ready it hey is Tony ready yet no I'm
bringing value I'm helping them with
their YouTube channel I'm giving them
suggestions uh I'm helping promote their
events I was doing stuff to try to still
be in the circle to stay top of mind so
that when the next opportunity came up
which happened to be when he launched
his next book to say I want to be top of
mind and Tony agreed to do five
different remote interviews uh for the
for his new book and I was one of the
five and and his team said you've been
so valuable to us you've been helping us
so much we appreciate it uh we want you
to be one of the five that Tony does at
an interview with like it's happening
it's Hof Pinch Me for real this time I
hope it's happening and then the day of
he showed up and and and I was super
stressed out and nervous about asking
the right questions and trying to bring
value again I don't want to disappoint
people and uh and it went he showed up
it went great we had an awesome
interview and at the end he then said
hey Evan uh I'd like to invite you as my
guest to my next uh seminar which is
coming up in uh New Jersey Unleashed
power within and he invited me to like
front row seats special lounge access
and all all the perks uh meet him
backstage because he wanted to chat and
take a picture which then led to more
events and other opport and then
speaking and then you know connecting
with Brendon Bard's team and like lots
of stuff happened through the Tony
Robbins world and
connection because I stayed and I
followed up because I kept trying to
bring value and even after the first
time when they got the cancellation on
me I still followed up for two more
years and kept providing value for two
more years right it's dog on the bone I
want this to work I'm going to find
another way through until finally it did
and then things took off and so so the
same thing for you and your business if
you want to have success it's about
thinking about ways you can provide more
value it's not that you can't provide
value it's not that you're not talented
not you're not a genius you are people
just don't recognize the value that you
can bring yet and you haven't figured
out how to bring that to Market in a way
that you're going to get paid to do it
what are some steps that you think
people should take or can take uh to get
that momentum to add more of that to
their life I think it starts with
identifying where do you lack right like
what do you want to get better at so for
you it's like hey I want to be a better
Entre r preneur i don't have business
people in my life so I'm going to make
an effort to be around people who are
more successful at that thing so if you
have a health goal or relationship goal
business goal they don't it's not that
you have to hang your on Elon Musk to
get it right I mean there's lots of
people who've done it if if it's a
relationship goal who are the happiest
couples that you know and try to spend
more time with them or health goal who
are the people who are running you know
or or just working out on their own and
how do you spend more time with them
when you're in that Circle you'll just
do a lot more so what is is the thing
that you are lacking um and then I would
split that
between uh moments like an event or
conference or hanging out with somebody
and then what can you do consistently on
The Daily right so what ends up
happening is you get really motivated
you go to a conference you meet some
people you learn and it takes you to
another level but then it's easy to fall
back down to you know where you were
like Oh I thought I could I thought I
could write a book like I can't write a
book I'm not going to start a show I
can't what where did I think I could do
that from because you've been taken out
of the environment put back into your
current environment so it's harder to to
get going again not impossible but just
harder but I love those moments because
it shows what's possible and I'm a big
believer that the ideas that come to you
when you're feeling bold powerful
confident courageous are actually the
right ones for you like those are your
best ideas and then your head talks you
down from doing them because it doesn't
it only understands a world that
currently exists like well you didn't go
to school for this what you're going to
be an entrepreneur you can't be an
entrepreneur right like the head starts
take over so those ideas that came to
you when you're at that conference
you're around these people like those
are actually the right ones for you and
you need to then inject new things daily
to remind yourself of the person you
want to be so that's why I have things
like my YouTube channel right because I
need a daily because I want to be around
uh I want to be around Oprah Winfrey and
Steve Jobs and Elon Musk and Bill Gates
and these people every day that when I'm
watching their video it makes me want to
go and do more was the serving the
purpose to serve was also a kind of like
something serving yourself too was that
were you attached to that
serving yeah I mean the ultimate form of
happiness is serving yeah I know if you
want fulfillment it doesn't exist unless
I don't think it exist unless you are
serving other people like I think as
humans we want to wake up and feel like
today is going to matter everybody wants
to wake up and feel like today is going
to matter and mean something to somebody
else and some of us you know you and I
we want to impact the world we want to
have a big you know ripple effect fact
that our positivity you know reaches
everybody and other people you know my
wife they just want to serve the closest
people in our family you know like the
25 closest people to us but in either
case we all want to wake up and feel
like today is going to matter and mean
something to somebody else if you woke
up every day and felt like it didn't
matter if you woke up today and felt
like nobody cares if I show up I'm not
doing anything meaningful my boss
doesn't care about me like it's just a
waste of time like that's the path to
depression and anxiety and stress and
suicide and all you know a lot of
problems that we have because people
don't feel like most people wake up and
drive to a job that they hate they don't
feel like what they're doing matters
where on the flip side if you woke up
and felt like today was going to matter
and mean something then you're much more
likely to show up with energy and hope
and optimism and so I'm trying to do
that for me every time I go and help
somebody I feel better right so it's
like this is part of like we are we are
interconnected as humans where we want
to feel like we're going to do something
that's going to mean something to
somebody else walk us through an average
every day for you as a high
performer well average every day or or
when I was on tour doing 90 Days Tour on
tour on tour on tour so part of the
reason for doing the tour was I was
afraid of speaking and i' done a lot of
speaking but it was always just like uh
you you speak and then it you're scared
and then I come back home and then I'm
fine and then I was I I wanted to get
rid of this fear speaking and so I
thought okay I'm just going to go and do
23 cities and every four days speak
again every 3 four days like a new new
city do it again do it again do it again
do it get my reps in and that became the
starting point so every fourth day
basically I was in a new city speaking
uh every fourth day we also had to
travel we still had to work uh and I
wanted to spend some time with nah it
was me nah and my cameraman Danny for 90
days together Hotel hopping Airbnb
hopping it was it was a pretty chaotic
but fun ride what do you think is the
best part about being an entrepreneur
and what's the scariest part if you had
the kind of worn would be entrepreneurs
out
there I think the reason you get into
entrepreneurship uh has to has to be
strong that you're moving towards
something not away from something hating
your job is not a good enough reason uh
having a bad boss is not a good enough
reason having toxic people around you in
your workplace means you should get out
of that but that's not the reason that
go be an entrepreneur because you're
going to work harder as an entrepreneur
than you will yes job right now now
you're you get yes you get to set the
rules and you get to decide what you
want to do but if if you're only in it
because of Freedom that's the wrong
reason you have to be in it because you
want to make an impact you have to want
to serve I I believe that humans are
built to serve I think it's in all of us
I think it's hardwired into into us uh
and that how do you serve well your
purpose comes from your pain that the
thing that you struggled with the most
in life whatever the most painful moment
of your life was helping other people
not go through the same thing that you
went through will be the thing that will
fill you up for life and it will never
get old and so that's the thing that
people need to find I love helping
entrepreneurs because I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur so I want to I
want to now pay it forward and help
others and that's that's everybody so
you need to figure out what's the what's
the going to that you're you're creating
not the moving away from and then how
you're going to serve and if you if you
do that you'll have success I think most
entrepreneurs when they get started
they're doing it for the wrong reasons
because they just don't like their job
and then they're just chasing an
opportunity they don't actually love the
thing but this is a hot thing to do in
2019 2020 2021 so that's what I'm going
to do but if you don't love that thing
you're going to lose um so that's the
biggest mistake most entrepreneurs make
for people who don't know what their
direction is where they want to go you
said try different things until you find
something that works for you like can
you elaborate on that or yeah at the
beginning it's it's a messy process
because you you grow up in a circle and
it's getting easier with YouTube and
internet Etc but uh if you grew up I
think of me growing up who did I know
it's my parents my family my school
you're kind of restricted by your
environment now at least we have YouTube
videos and you can learn whatever you
want to learn there's people out
there when you're struggling to figure
out what your career should be or what
your next move should be I think you'll
have moments in life where you have
absolute Clarity you know like maybe
you're in a moment now of absolute
Clarity I want to get my podcast
actually like kicking ass yeah right so
that's where like Blinder on and go kick
ass on your podcast right you don't need
more you don't need to get into nfts and
like some Ai and crazy stuff like go go
kickass in your podcast when you have
Clarity and there's other moments in
life and it's not just a per like you
have moments in life where you don't
know what to do next you sell your
podcast it blows up you sell it and
you're done it's like oh wow what do I
do and that's where you expand open to
say okay I need to try a bunch of stuff
to see what connects with me so should
everybody be an entrepreneur no but
should everybody try yeah cuz how do you
know you know should everybody love
sushi no but should everybody try yeah
cuz how do you know your favorite food
is if you only eat pizza and hot dogs
all day self- L comes from doing
difficult things self- Lov
self-confidence self respect all of it
comes from doing difficult things and
praising yourself for doing them I think
it's one of the most important things
that people don't do enough but I think
in order to actually make the praise
stick you have to prove to yourself that
you're worthy of it by doing difficult
things you can say I'm a badass
entrepreneur you can say say I'm amazing
and I love myself but what your brain's
ain't going to say well no you don't no
you don't show me what have you done you
you're you're waking up and doing the
same thing you did yesterday at least
this is the conversation in my head so
by doing difficult things by doing the
thing even if you don't get the result
it doesn't matter but the result you're
tying your selfworth your
self-confidence to the effort to trying
the difficult thing to taking action on
a difficult thing that you were scared
to do if you woke up every day and did
something that made you scared that was
difficult that made your heart go boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom like that
you did that every day and then you
praised yourself afterwards for the
effort I promise you you're going to
love yourself I promise you you're going
to go off and do amazing things you're
going to take that idea that you've got
and go off and actually execute it and
actually implement it one of the biggest
reasons why you're not is because you
don't believe in yourself that's why I
think lack of belief is the single
biggest problem in the world I'm trying
to solve the world's biggest problem
people don't believe in themselves
enough the woman who solves cancer is a
manager at some restaurant and she hates
her life because she never believed in
herself enough to actually go down the
path that she should have gone down
because she listened to her parents and
friends and family and Society to go do
the safe thing and she's got a safe
boring life that she hates cuz she
doesn't love herself and she doesn't
believe in herself enough and so you
have to do the things that make you
scared that are difficult that are
difficult it's not about it's not about
being Fearless it's about feeling the
fear and still going off and doing it
and then saying I'm amazing cuz I tried
because if you woke up every day and did
something where you felt amazing that
you tried you're going to actually go
off and accomplish amazing things and
you're going to feel amazing about
yourself because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the the work to
actually get it but you are different
you are special believe Nation you made
it here all the way to the end and I
love you so as a special celebration if
you put a hasht believe down in the
comments Below on this video I will
showcase you and celebrate you somewhere
on the screen in a future video because
you are awesome for 10 more rules from
Gary vaynerchuk check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe I'll see you there I
don't think anybody can work hard hard
unless they like it I was the least
hardworking student I was selling
lemonade and shoveling snow and washing
cars and selling baseball cards every
day